juste livrés l'enseigne de la nouvelle
librairie d'occasion peut enfin être
apposée baptisé livres au trésor
elle a en effet tout d'une caverne d'ali
baba j'ai mille tout ce qui est guide
sur les villes
je les ai mis là bas avec le touriste on
me bats depuis le début des années 2000
dominique et hubert vente uniquement sur
internet
au total ils ont cent soixante mille
ouvrages anciens et d'occasion
référencés sur leur site des livres
qu'ils expédient depuis la base a joué
mais l'augmentation des frais sur
internet les a incités à se remettre en
question on en est arrivé à la situation
suivante tous les livres d'une valeur
unitaire inférieur à 10 euros génère des
pertes
il n'a pas il n'est pas est absolument
exclu de continuer dans ces conditions
c'est ce qui nous a amenés à revenir
vers le marché traditionnel essayer de
rétablir un lien de proximité avec les
clients pour attirer le client justement
les livres de poche sont vendu 2 euros
pièce et 30 mille ouvrages en tout genre
vont remplir à terme ses étagères il
compte aussi attiré des bibliophiles
le but c'est aussi que les clients qui
vont rentrer dans cette boutique puisse
consulter notre site internet et trouver
sur ce site
le livre évidemment qui n'est pas dans
la boutique ici mais un livre plus
confidentielles ou une édition originale
ou un livre illustré qui cherche depuis
longtemps et dont ils pourront disposer
dans les 24 heures
mais encore faut-il attirer le client
dans cette zone rurale au sud de l'eure
et loir c'est à nous ensuite de faire de
faire en sorte qu'il y ait suffisamment
de
d'animation suffisamment qui se passe
des choses pour faire venir les gens on
a il ya une clientèle potentielle
ces libraires ont déjà une clientèle
d'anglais et il espère que la
localisation leur permettra de toucher
des lecteurs de l'orne de la sarthe et
du loir et cher